well tonight a north las vegas woman's
desperate plea for you to consider
getting the copic vaccine as she just
lost her daughter to the virus and now
her son is fighting for his life
victoria saha tells us how painful it
was for this woman to watch the virus
just tear up her family this is the
story
mom it hurts it hurts i can't breathe
jamie patrick recalls one of the last
conversations she had with her daughter
brandi less than a month ago she just
said mom i just want you to know if i
don't make it through this i love you
patrick tells me her daughter didn't get
the vaccine because she was afraid of
the side effects however once diagnosed
with covet in july her condition quickly
deteriorated she was
so bad they put her in icu right away
texts sent to her mom from the hospital
say i can't breathe patrick says doctors
did everything they could but as brandy
was being intubated she went into
cardiac arrest they do cpr they break
bones and you can hear them crushing in
their chest you know and
and they worked hard in the midst of all
of this her son dustin also not
vaccinated was admitted to the hospital
with covid and is now in the icu i miss
her so much
i haven't even had a chance to grieve
her because i'm so worried about dustin
he's he's minute by minute critical
patrick says she did get vaccinated and
firmly believes it saved her life and
now her son has second thoughts he says
wait till i get out i'm going to tell
all my friends go get the shot go get
the shot don't be fooling around as
dustin fights to live patrick is doing
what she can to be nearby usually
between midnight and 6 a.m i'm sleeping
in the parking lot just
hoping i don't get that call because i
don't want to get that call and leave
some text messages even though he can't
see them right now when he gets out
he'll have a book to read
victoria saha 8 news now
patrick says she doesn't want another
family to go through the same heartache
which is why she hopes this story will
help push more people to get vaccinated
doctors say if her son dustin does pull
through there's a good chance he could
have to get a lung transplant the family
has set up a gofundme page to help with
medical bills and that link is on our
website